production continues on Wonder Woman the
big-budget DC superhero adventure due
for release in 2017 new pictures have
now leaked from the London set seeming
to confirm an early 20th century setting
for at least part of the film I'm Kate
and this is your gamespot news update
the period detail in these images seems
to confirm October's rumors that part of
the film would be set during World War
one it is expected that the movie will
also take place on the ancient island of
their mascara the home of wonder woman
and her fellow Amazons last month of
full cast list for the movie was
announced joining star gal Godot will be
Star Trek's Chris Pine as Captain Steve
Trevor Plus Robin Reich Danny Huston
David Thewlis Ewen Bremner and elena
anaya speaking to interview magazine
earlier this year gado explained what
threw her to the role I feel like I've
been given a huge opportunity to inspire
people and not only women she said and
not because of me but because of who
wonder woman is and what she stands for
there's a lot of responsibility but I
have the best team and the best people
to work with it's going to be an amazing
ride we've also seen the new Batman vs
Superman trailer which features Wonder
Woman right at the end spoilers though
it does seem a bit unfair the bat from
soups get trousers and she doesn't is
cold outside what do you think of the
leaked photos are DC matching up to
marvel let us know in the comments I'm
Katie you can find me on Twitter at how
not to draw and remember to keep it
gamespot com for all your gaming and
entertainment news